he's well known for inspiring and
motivating people from all walks of life
he's visited 75 countries and has spoken
to millions of people he began the
church in California called the
congregation he's Tim story and here's
my take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't settle in hell
so watch you have momentum look at me
you have momentum imma be yama B imma
imma imma be momentum and then BAM you
get BAM in it and then BAM the waves of
life hit BAM and then many people have a
setback a setback it could be a
relationship it was looking so good the
first three dates now you got a change
in numbers right asset back divorce
setback financial setback physical
setback illness setback somebody passed
in our lives setback when most people
have a setback watch they take a step
back then a setback and a step back in a
setback in a step back and now watch you
find yourself so far away from the real
you and people many times sit in that
setback
I don't mind you going through a tough
time and staying there for a week or a
month or a year but a decade so some
people sit they said some people settles
they settle and that's what we're headed
today because a lot of you that are
watching here today you have been
settling in your setback and you have
therefore become a discount version of
yourself
well you don't understand what I've been
through Tim's story
mr. live coach to the stars oh really we
all been through hell but to quote
Winston Churchill when you're going
through hell don't stop don't pitch a
tent inhale don't build a Holiday Inn
inhale come on somebody don't even put a
Ritz Carlton in your hair well number
two work your land
proverbs 12:11 he who works his land
shall have abundance
whoever chases fantasy's lacks wisdom
there's my life hmm he who works as land
what's my land Tim story if you're in
the fifth grade work in fence bait land
if you're a single mother work your land
if you're overweight work your land get
a shape he who works his land shall have
the word shall means certainly it's
fixed it's determined hmm you shall have
what abundance abundance is overflowing
more than enough
I am freakish at work in my land I am a
working machine I I'm in the middle of a
companies mmm I'm doing movies at a high
level I'm doing plays rehab recovery
which we'll talk about later I'm in the
middle of the restaurant business now
I'm working my land
mmm so I'm up most mornings about 4:45
like you I go to the gym I work in my
land yeah so vests and teeth the
Gonzales my mother when she was so hard
on me to do the dishes correctly she was
teaching me to work my land hmm so one
thing you will always get from me is I
will damn work my land yeah I worked my
land and it gave me abundance mmm
because it's a law of the harvest and
I'll work you through this it'll take me
literally 60 second do it you got a plow
the ground mm-hmm to plant the seed to
water the seed to get the harvest yes so
your whole life their bonus or is what's
happened to you right okay you even plow
and plow and plow and plow and plow and
plow
okay a hard work planting planting
planting planting by faith yes
watering by faith yes and paydays on its
way yes
so payday hit you and your wife yes in
this wild way why cuz it says it's gonna
happen that's right he who works his
land shall have abundance overflowing
rule number three learned to say no I
can't always make financial decisions
based on emotions and because I feel for
people I feel sorry for somebody and so
a lot of people approach me with
projects yeah so I could be in the in
the airport hey Tim story I got this
invention or product yeah
and I really think that sometimes I took
on some that I should not write right
right because that person did not pay
the price mm-hmm they just want to use
my contacts to do it and it it just made
me too busy and my life was too
cluttered yeah so I had to declare in my
life from some of these projects yeah
sometimes in order to stay on our
priority pathway yeah you got to say no
kind of thing so I really become a
master of saying that's just not working
for me
but in years past I was too cluttered
rule number four get your shout back
most people you know when you when we
were kids yeah there's a shout right
yeah parents always go Shh it's coming
in and out of the door you're shouting
yeah and the parents never go into a
kid's room and say turn up the volume
they were in the classroom because kids
there's a volume to life but the more we
get challenged and disappointed
disappointment is an amazing thing the
scriptures say that disappointment can
make you heart sick well that's bad
because the heart is the center it's
your core yeah joy comes from the heart
peace faith so when you're disappointed
in your heart is sick it could take away
your shout so life okay that's why I
shout out of you yeah doctor shout out
it
yes and so with my father passing that
could have knocked the shout out of me
and I could have stayed that way or
someone who's been in a car accident or
someone who started a business and it
didn't work or someone who thought you
know certain things we're gonna happen
their lives and now they're disappointed
but there are ways to get your shout
back yeah
when life tries to take me down to a
whisper mm-hmm just shout on purpose
just intentionally shout sometimes I am
driving it on the freeway and I'll just
just think about things that are going
right so it's not always a verbal shout
it's a it's an inward shout of choosing
to say hey this is something out about
I'm still alive yeah you know a lot of
people like to complain about their age
I'm already 50 to 70 was out about yeah
so we could we could take and have a
little just a moment every day and just
remember thank god we're still alive
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
it's free the link to join is in the
description below do you want to change
your life my friends you've got to
change your physiology and you got to
change your focus and even though I'm
gonna sell you the most beautiful hammer
I'm not gonna guarantee the
instructional integrity of the house the
minute you begin to get external in your
life worrying about what other people
think about you right you vote you've
lost all control you and it never fills
you up rule number five don't get
dramatic I don't respond yeah when
people are expect me to respond a
certain way and a saying that I've been
saying for years now is don't get
dramatic in the midst of the drama mmm
I could have 19 dramatic things hit me
at once and you will not see it happen
my right arm could be blown off mm-hmm
and you won't know my right arms bone
that's amazing that is the number one
quality of the really great leaders
people of influence that I've
experienced rule number six be open to
new things
when I went to college
started staying all the healing
ministers you know Jaco william branham
Oral Roberts I got so filled with signs
and wonders I just started with
releasing that for like the first 17
years of my ministry Wow
but I always knew there was more and
you're gonna find that that even though
older you get like man I'm doing some
neat things and thank God for but
there's something more
so I started being open to that
something more it wasn't just that God
wanted to just make me Tim story healing
minister but also doing plays working on
movies life coaching people dream
Academy yeah so it's been open to them
well number seven live in the moment I'm
learning to be in the moment see like
right now we're driving in this Range
Rover headed over to my hotel yeah yeah
I'm in the moment yeah I'm with Grant
Cardone I'm in the moment when I was
younger I was always thinking about
what's next that was missing these great
moments that make sense yeah I still do
that but the reason is taking me a
seconds cuz I know I'm still yeah I'm
always produced in the future yeah I do
miss him I I'm more in the moment and
that's awesome
yeah I I tell you I really am I was just
in Vienna Austria and not in the past I
i yes see but I was I was at a museum
mm-hmm and I was just going all slow you
could hear the shuffling of the feet I
was in the moment yeah yeah so that's
that that that's a an area of growth in
my life so number eight be elegant
growing up again with sisters and
respecting them respect to my mother's
hard work even though I was good in
sports I didn't I didn't need to talk
about it I didn't need to show off yeah
then I saw guys that were elegant and
powerful mmm
like I I look at a guy like Sidney
Poitier great example such class such
style and yet very understated yeah
and there's there's a scripture in the
Bible that says only a fool tells his
whole heart and I was always a master
chess player in my mind then I knew I
was gonna be Tim story but I didn't feel
the need to tell people about it
rule number nine have the right mindset
a miracle mindset is your VIP card to
anywhere I get in anywhere because of my
miracle mindset when you get a miracle
mentality it is your VIP card anywhere
you cannot be stopped everybody has a
mindset a mindset is a point of view the
way you see things so people could look
at what's happening with government
shutdown and all these things and get
all nervous
a miracle mindset says that's going on
but my God is greater so a miracle a
miracle is supernatural it's uncommon
it's not regular so when you have a mind
set of a miracle mindset your
perspective is always God will make a
way where there wasn't a way a miracle
mindset again is your VIP pass anywhere
you cannot be stopped with the right
mindset and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
don't live in almost life there are
three levels of living almost most in
utmost almost means not quite I almost
was happy matcom almost work
I almost lost the weight I was raised in
an almost family to start my mother is
Spanish Vasanti Gonzalez and she had a
sixth grade education worked at a place
called Winchell's donuts yup anybody
ever been there
my father steel worker bethlehem steel
10th grade education and so when we want
to converse tennis shoes we almost got
converse Levi's we got plea buys so you
almost start getting stuck in an almost
life try that say stuck in an almost
life but then one day some people gave
us tickets to go to a place called
Disneyland also known a ka as a happiest
place on earth and as an eight-year-old
I went to Disneyland and my life changed
because I went around Disneyland and
they had like Tomorrowland in
Frontierland and they had a a bear that
was singing and then they had it's a
small world but when I went on it's a
small world I'm telling you my eyes got
super giant because I saw all these
countries and it connected me to the
person that I was really supposed to be
that even though I was trapped in an
almost situation I am an utmost person
see the real you will make a demand on
the you that you've become
you are never created to be almost nor
were you created to be most to be most
means there's a ceiling if I was to let
go a helium balloon today even though
the ceilings are so high there's a
ceiling but where you're headed in 2015
16 17 18 19 20 there is no ceiling
somebody clap if you believe that now
I've got a really special bonus tip from
Tim on how to overcome crisis that I
think you're going to
joy but before that some of the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the almost life that you're
living and need to get out of number two
what's the mindset shift that you need
to make and number three what new thing
can you try in your life this week you
know one of the ways you work through
crisis number one is you have to become
awake and then number two you got to
take inventory so I'm awake and I take
inventory or crap what do I what did I
do to myself and then thirdly you got to
look for help
people stronger than yourself okay and
then the fourth thing you got to do is
you got to cooperate with your comeback
so just those principles alone we've
untied the knots of some of the greatest
minds in the world
if you want to see the top 10 I did an
Oprah Winfrey check it to be there right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there my well-being my wholeness my
everything is knowing who I am and where
I come from